princess Charlotte cries as she honors
her late great-grandmother Queen
Elizabeth I think when you look at the
Cambridge children they have had so much
change in the last couple of weeks
um you you have to you have to remember
how young they are
as kids Prince George and Princess
Charlotte attended the Queen's State
funeral notably absent their little
brother Prince Louie
following the service at Westminster
Abbey Charlotte couldn't hold back her
tears that's the seven-year-old crying
with her mom trying to console her
more focus in the spotlight a greater
shift to the media gaze I think this has
probably come sooner than William would
have hoped that it would
um but the death of the queen and the
accession of King Charles has a huge
impact on William Kate and their
children and I think we'll see the
evidence of that in the coming weeks and
months Prince Harry's wife Meghan Markle
also got emotional during the funeral
check out the Duchess of Sussex with her
head bound down and hand up to her face
as Sophie the Countess of Wessex wife of
Prince Edward Comforts her there's also
this moment outside Megan wiping away a
tear as the procession continues I think
from that we can read that every effort
is being made by the royal family to
include the sussexes in this historic
poignant and deeply moving time for the
Royal Family
[Music]